The multiverse it's dangerous i could use an
avenger it's about time you showed up on may 6th
enter a world
of strange try not to break the
multiverse stephen oh come on
sam raimi's doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness that is a dream come true
i got a call from my agent saying that kevin feige
and the marvel team were looking for a director
for the new doctor strange movie and i was a big
fan of the first one it was really intelligent and
interesting so when that offer came and i thought
this would be a really good challenge ready to go
sam is such a lovely human being
and obviously he's standing in this
industry and this genre in particular
is legendary as it should be
sam has become known for this terrorizing
cinema experience creating as much tension
as possible for the audience just ready
for them to have that jump scare moment
and that was always where we were
headed with the sequel to doctor strange
knowing that we wanted to explore
the mind-bending frightening side
the multiverse we need your help with
what what do you know about the multiverse
telling the story was such a
gigantic endeavor and there's
a lot of dimensionalized visuals
that we use in telling that story
we shot it with an eye toward that so i think it's
going to be a very exciting experience to go to 3d
you open the doorway between universes and we
don't know who or what will walk through it
Welcome back everyone this will be my new marvel
doctor strange 2 trailer video there's a whole
bunch of new footage they released they're also
talking a lot about what's going on with vision
inside the mcu so i'll talk about vision during
this video too they mentioned him during the
previous trailers and vision is coming back
but he's white vision right now and doctor
strange trying to use some of the power of the
gods they're specific to his comics in the way
he uses his powers in the comics i'll explain how
that's all connected to what's happening on moon
knight and thor love and thunder right now too
if you're brand new to the channel we're doing
a giveaway for imax tickets all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite easter egg from all the trailers
because the movie is coming out really soon
just a reminder that i will do full videos for
everything easter eggs post credit scene videos
all that stuff when the movie does actually come
out but just starting with the brand new footage
first there's a new scene of what looks like
doctor strange sitting in a restaurant talking to
america chavez for the first time talking
about the multiverse like it looks like her
shorter brown hair because he's been having
this nightmare about the multiverse and the
destruction of the mcu after the events of
spiderman no way home so he thought that he
fixed everything that spider-man helped him break
but turns out things were getting way worse so the
way they're using her in the mcu is saying that
she is the only character that they have on hand
who can physically travel to alternate universes
and this whole story is about them traveling
to other universes they said that's why this
movie is meant to be different from spiderman
no way home in spiderman no way home it was all
about characters from the multiverse like tobey
maguire andrew garfield's versions of spiderman
all the multiverse sinister six characters
coming to the mcu now it's the reverse them
going to other universes i am spider-man in my
world but it seems like what's going on in this
restaurant when they're talking for the first
time is it's meant to be a reference to that
spider-man 2 restaurant scene because it's sam
raimi we're talking about here he's the one who
directed that original tobey maguire scene where
doctor octopus threw a bus through the window
at tobey maguire spiderman to get his attention
now it seems like there's a version of
that happening inside doctors train 2
except it's gargantos going crazy in the streets
that gets their attention notice he has all the
runes on him which seems similar to the runes that
are on the other chaos magic looking monster later
in the film so it just seems like someone is
controlling him maybe scarlet witch trying to
get at america chavez using her power of traveling
across the multiverse to try and find a version of
billy and tommy there's a brand new scene of mcu
doctor strange later in the film because he has
the blue patch on his cloak of levitation
now he doesn't have it earlier in the film
he's looking at the book of the vashanti up close
if you're not a big comic book reader the vishanti
are basically the place in the comics where doctor
strange gets all of his power from to power his
spells remember big connection to moon knight
what's happening during thor love and thunder
we're learning more about the mcu gods there are
legit gods in the mcu the vashanti are literally
called the ones who sit above it sounds like in
the mcu they're going to say that they exist in
a higher level dimension kind of like the gods
from the moon knight series their team is made up
of auster hogoth and agamotto who are all kind of
like members of the old gods pantheon agamoto is
kind of an exception like doctor strange wears the
literal eye of agamotto agamotto was the original
sorcerer supreme inside the main mcu dimension
but agamoto himself is kind of like a thor type
character like he was born with god to your
powers he's the son of the other member of the
vishanti named oster who was one of the old gods
so it's like odin attaining god level power then
passing that power on biologically to thor so when
agamotto was young he just lived amongst humans
became sorcerer's supreme and then eventually
he transitioned to a more god-level state being
part of this vishanti trio they're meant to be the
sworn enemies of really powerful cosmic characters
like dormammu schumagorth cathone the darkhold the
darkhold and chaos magic obviously being one of
the big macguffins during the movie one of the big
causes for a lot of these problems so it sounds
like they're using the book of the vashanti in the
film as sort of a counter to what's happening with
the multiverse going crazy all the chaos magic and
scarlet witch with the dark hold then there's the
funny scene of doctor strange literally trying
to pick up the bus and just throw it whole
at gargantos and him just throwing it right back
at him when this happens you also get a really
good look at it there's a big number on it numbers
on things like this especially really obvious ones
are always meant to be easter eggs but here's
the thing none of the characters in this scene
or any of the really big characters in the film
debuted in 1961 aside from the fantastic four the
fantastic four are like the only really really big
characters that started in 1961 it does seem like
one of the members of the multiverse illuminati
could be the fox marvel version of reed richards
from those classic fantastic four movies the 92
might be a reference to avengers west coast annual
which was in 1992 where scarlet witch remembered
her children billy and tommy for the first time
and it caused a whole bunch of problems sometimes
numbers on things like this are also just meant to
be birthdays for people who worked on the movie
or involved with the movie in some way so if
you think you know what this easter egg is meant
to be 61.92 just write it below in the comments
there's also another joke on the back of the
bus too when it's flying at them the sign reads
unlock a better day right as gargantos is throwing
the entire bus back at them like have a better day
if you notice the license plate on the yellow
cab over here on the right it says p-307
that could be a reference to sam raimi's last
marvel movie being spider-man 3 in 2007 with a
version of peter parker played by tobey maguire
that we just saw during spider-man no way home
also on the left side of the frame there's a
phone booth that says magic plus t and they're
in the middle of a giant magical battle there's
another brand new scene of defender strange also
helping america chavez and mcu doctor strange
inside this realm where they're trying to get
to the book of the vishanti before it seems like
his body's been corrupted and he's been turned
into a version of a marvel zombie it also seems
like one of the versions of doctor strange traps
mcu scarlet witch inside the mirror dimension like
we just saw happen during spider-man no way home
this is also probably one of those scenes just to
show you how powerful scarlet witch is compared to
other marvel characters like she'll probably break
out of this really quickly compared to doctor
strange during spider-man no way home he was
trapped in the mirror dimension for a couple hours
she'll probably break right out of it then there's
the scene of scarlet witch inside comartage or the
darkhold temple before it seems like everything
goes completely crazy with the darkhold and it
seems like she's telling msu doctor strange not to
break the multiverse also zoom in enhance behind
her here notice this giant symbol that's the
same symbol from the celestials so it's a big
connection to the eternals movie too and i think
they're just trying to draw this reference to the
ancient nature of this temple and all the magic
that they're playing with like this is all meant
to go back to the dawn of humanity obviously
agamoto would also be going back to the dawn
of humanity where the celestials first targeted
planet earth then for those of you asking about
what's going on with vision during the events of
the movie what's going on with white vision and
what's going on with paul bettany just in general
coming back during marvel phase four because paul
bettany was making all these references about
coming back like oh yeah i'm definitely coming
back but we've already seen that scene of scarlet
witch in the trailers referencing vision during
the movie calling him viz we might also see
a version of him during the nightmares that
she's seeing every day about billy and tommy well
there's a couple different versions of westview in
a couple different versions of scarlet witch that
we see in the film this version of billy and tommy
that we see seems like it's our mcu scarlet witch
having nightmares that she's talking about during
the trailer like she's seeing visions of billy and
tommy but this isn't actually the real version of
billy and tommy so because she's hallucinating
the events of west view again remembering billy
and tommy we also might see a version of vision
pop up in those nightmares too and because so
much of vision's identity and his origin is
connected to jarvis and iron man and sword was
trying to weaponize him again during Wandavision
he might also come back during the iron man armor
war series next year too as white vision like
white vision coming back basically what happened
to white vision at the end of Wandavision is
that he just got all of his memories unlocked
remember he is the original version of vision
from the mcu he has total control over what
he looks like so he can make himself look like
whatever he wants to that's why when hex vision
unlocks all of his original memories his eyes
start looking like original visions eyes again
but if you have any big questions or you spotted
any easter eggs in the trailers that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in
the comments i have a brand new thor love and
thunder trailer video they released that i'll do
a video for tomorrow make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my brand new moon knight episode
5 trailer video and click here for my full
moon knight episode 4 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!